being molested by my father and my
mother married to I'm the only one with
a different father you just heard of me
to this day I say you do nothing she'll
tell me you should say something
what's something like they're being done
by our Father so my debt your mother is
married so how do they say something
like they're always with me always give
me a mother supposed to protect our
child you hear me to this day
see we're not owning up to it but when
it means I don't heard I'd be affected
me I'll leave here so you hear me it
gave it life to the Lord if you asked me
to forgive you man I did I did because
if you don't forgive somebody along
won't forgive you with my mother it's
all because of huh you hear me
this woman remarried again you hear me
at the age of 52
I was 52 years old I'm gonna be with
this man for my third son year maybe
even longer here comes your boy again
you hear me
you come deja vu huh you got a husband
yeah he'll serve
what's PCP you know marijuana you know
crack cocaine
how you doing crystal hmm
hit the dope huh didn't you come around
the back of the house and peep through
my bedroom window
this is this one really made my mother
have better jealous spirit in her
she always fixing what she and him
getting each other me and she know I'm
gonna come to our rescue and about me
stepping in trying to rescue her because
of how are you talking to her she was
the bread - mmm man will turn around and
put me out the house it was all like a
booby trapped by her from the kid go hmm
she new husband her husband her second
husband can't warn me she knew it mm-hmm
and when he couldn't have me go I don't
know where to go it was always way she
cared about him and only him and so I
always got the law I feel are you gonna
whoop you I'm gonna go whoop you even
though you've been whoop you hear me
holidays she allowed to happen to me for
my child all the way down see a man in
my fifties come over here I asked my mom
cuz I had nowhere to go
oh you hear me was go I go don't forget
another stuff I've been going through
she told me I could you got two couches
in the living room my mom was sleeping
one couch and I got me some redstone
about the council both couch faced one
another when I woke up my mother's
husband man on the flow but she oh no
the counting them all never I'm sleeping
like this when I woke up this man had my
hand playing with the tip of his teeth
what's a lay upon the couch and play
like she's sleeping huh she never sleep
because he always on just because you
have to stay woke just to me she could
keep an eye on him so I say cold days
are more dear bye Jim that's could I get
some rest something to go lay in huh
mm-hmm a bid that she don't sleep in
because they don't sleep in the bed
together they got seven bedrooms yeah I
wake up and your husband okay me got
blood naked in a beer with me I jumped
about to be it ran in there
curled up on the floor like I was a dog
we had a dog named precious I just
curled up like she don't know nothing
that happening they all ready to take me
about no ministration my boys cooking no
nothing he ever did teach me none today
I don't know what it was about me and my
mom had allowed a lot of things to
happen to me
starting from being a child so to this
day coming here to California played a
big part in my life my mom me getting
away from her
I still lived in I still live in the
house with my mother listen she killing
things happen I couldn't never take a
bath in our house unless she was dead he
killed me when he said well I can't have
both of y'all you hear me
not him to go back and tell my mom none
of this stuff see a lot of she knew it
mm-hmm
when she plays sleep like she did when
daddy number one will come in my room he
laid Daniel and your bed and play sleep
like you didn't know he was in my room
now he reels me you and husband number
two in the front living room here on the
couch playing possum
yeah she sleep like you know the older
you get you get less asleep my momma 77
I picture 70 I mean when she was 20
years old
the biggest reason why I came here I had
needed to really find the Lord and
she'll try to grab on to the Lord at
home and she'll say you ain't got God in
you you don't even know God she'll say
things and she'll make up lies and have
my sister me I'm thinking
China hurt her just jealous spirit by
today my mom still with that man she
still look at me
he always say well I can't help OPI well
I can't help oh yeah this may was
something else he should just go home
with his life I couldn't believe my
mother I call her
I got my mother right now a monster
because she is warned what mother gonna
let a child give him a left in me I
never talked about this yesterday you
interview me o lot of mercy Jesus what
mother would let her child give
molesting him he gave me the last name
he raised me I still stuck with him it
caught him day after being molested by
this man all the way down groan you hear
me
and she had a skeleton in the closet
sequencing she'll still denied to this
day don't say something I'm the only one
in my family ever got oh I came from a
good family a good old-fashioned family
what mother don't let a child give my
listen and don't do nothing a mother
supposed to protect I hear about kids
getting molested outside but not the
mother knowing about it she let it go on
for a while until one day we came home
from school my mother making we packed
all our stuff up to leave to move out
and leave my dad she didn't tell us why
we were leaving my dad but I knew I I
guessed it I was letting my two sisters
know up under me by me being the oldest
child in the tomboy to not let nothing
happen to them deal I open mom I will
say something this lady kept you I told
him what he got ready to die
I couldn't wait I couldn't wait daddy
died coming out to Kali with your
skeleton because that's the mother who
talked Braille Rob use to me
Rob used to me I will no bad job I was a
good job there for me not to go to
counseling but mother and I said Missy
no dentist
I turned me upside down that turned me
upside down you hear me
I got one boy I didn't want no more kids
in life I said not send me a girl
because what happened to me oh I see my
son the way a mother it supposed to
treat a child you hear me because he had
a grandfather to get my mom ended up man
another guy oh my god oh Jesus it's my
mother
we battle rights to stay up 57 years old
Mirabelle to this day well I knew she
she did she can't put me devil rehab a a
family who don't do no drugs no smoking
no drink and in this one child this one
child comes up on all this different
type of [ __ ] there's one child the most
educated one in the family you hit me
the most educated one the census the
last thing she's on the jury I'm the
last lot of generation that's the same
every day every day I with the school
didn't I don't see nobody with nothing I
had on I'll go to the fabric store pick
out the type of fabric my parent my
mother made everything I wore my life to
I got off it's just over oh you know
can't keep me about no administration
getting about no boys I don't want him
unless when we taught me how to cook on
egg over easy
sunny-side up with a yolk you don't want
taught me how to
I didn't understand that you knew he was
doing this to me and she didn't want to
teach me nothing that I opposed to no
one's growing up so I had some first
cousins that would my look they daddy
was molesting them oh boy
what is this family but that one was bad
I can't believe me and my mom I still
feeling because she don't want ask me to
forgive her but you know am I really
about really forgave her it's like ya
know she's sticking with each other to
see someone god I remember he won't be
in her life no mo and I had done that
picture my mother knew just as she had
this beer alone or toys with me I think
my mom would be happy but take my life I
tried to do that I took all of
medications here three tight shield up
then I sat down in her chair it's not a
house I waited for her to come home for
work and I was hoping she would find me
dance a recliner
I just lost anyone time for me to go yet
because my mom came home and woke me up
she was so mad at me medication not
because of what I tried to do to myself
I had my handgun license hey Billy
brought in [ __ ] 32 or 38 but I have
read I sold drugs and up getting rid of
both my girls - dope girls yeah when I
did decide to take my life so have my
girls went in my possession no mo she
says instead of taking my
medication you should have shot yourself
in one of your pills
oh boy you have to bring me coming here
to California getting away from huh
that's wide enough he's dead
what's for me to grab on to the Lord
here we always I can't stay away from
her she wouldn't distract me from kind
of being my relationship with the Lord
yeah it made her mad that I can feel she
tried to scare me enough to come come
Hey oh no nobody here all I know is I
didn't either bill I'll be nice to you
but because I'm slipping again I'm
slipping into a state of mind
Oh giving up on life again and I wasn't
even all no drugs Paul I live here one
of Houston you hear me that woman not a
say some face to me that makes me wanna
give up on life when the Bible said get
the tongue it's full of deadly pauses
daddy cooked like a double-edged blade
I'm a witness
I'm a witness and this woman knows that
Jesus she say to me I'm gonna do what
makes her happy I knew I have no family
here but I knew I needed to grab on to
the Lord because that is my love you me
you got the look I say my God my god
I've got to love you huh do you know how
hard it is to live in the same house we
warned this ungodly and one is trying to
be godly
don't try to be God
say go give me all the way no one said
he won't bring him that the law won't
forget me [ __ ] I huncle don't try to
please him mommy dude I can't give
myself today I love coming here together
it's so hard here for me because me want
you to use your body for everything you
need
ain't got no morals no principles I did
that back in the eighties I had no sex I
miss you oh no dicks
I don't even give women that's what the
Lord made me stronger you hear me
that's why he made me stronger with my
body this time and my mind
sooner or later I'm ill I'm crossed all
the way over to the Lord come here make
you talk to the Lord I'm so scared here
it makes reach out to the Lord I'm doing
a whole lot better than the last
interview I don't gain some weight I'm
more often to my lord
I share the Bible with people you just
I'm just taking baby steps but before I
go back to Houston
I took they out of the Lord all the way
in me I got some because that's a demon
in her and we have real demons evil
spirits principalities swirling all
around we just can't see them you two
wanna take my life was evil for her to
say I should have shot myself in the air
with me monster he would toward things
to me in my sleep
cut my hair put plugs in it jury coming
up I mean
I really believe my box of oatmeal the
pocket of dry oatmeal great love
it's still my sister
ice I think somebody don't put so many
mouths meal she's really sure that's
crazy
no now would think family no just so
evil
like this yeah believe it but I mean do
no drugs it's something is helping me
sleep and no one you could give to me
it's because you know I love oatmeal day
and I dare night
pilot oatmeal I don't put it past him I
even talked to the police about me
getting some camera cuz I didn't need
nobody thinking I would cry because I
was I was calling crazy for real but
thinking that they were doing these
things to me
I guess what they were us hey was it
wasn't me they was doing these things to
me
then we'll she got with the man she
missing man no one he ten years like me
huh
yeah sure crack push alcohol I did 20 25
30 years y'all took the bathroom knob
off the dope I can't take no bathroom
that house unless my mama said I'd do
everything not to hurt her ain't go
against the grain because I know how
much she loves this man but I would
never go just to grant and mess with my
stepfather for money of my mother
hmm
The Stepfather stayed at the meet for
the longest ride coming up yeah this
woman will sleep on the couch in the
living room the stepfather had talked to
my mom so bad
ice company and nothing that man was
buying me like a man you hear me they
can't call my momma beg go ahead [ __ ] I
told him you didn't go sit down with
somebody called room I'm up their grade
beats I need him understand that because
I had to open my mouth but him doing
some bad language turn my mother's
Debray he gets a check 231 they don't
know she went no man get the whole
goddamn [ __ ] seed out of my dick he got
like that cook stead of him huh making
him play bills and responsibilities
picture things around the house she laid
it will go like she wanted him hmm
and he did he did try to go like she
like he just didn't know how boy he was
trying to go but I would tell my
everything okay he'll did Daisy boy
again I said mom can't come in and sleep
on the couch a couple hours I'm tired
cuz here put me out the house because of
my mouth but his mouthful yes is worse I
feel like here no bigger disrespecting
mom and she pay all the bills and
property taxes and you know so you won't
be disrespectful and didn't tell me that
you want both my bags help my mom net
part woo right to the day my mom still
with the same man ain't nowhere in the
world I can go back without my pool
armored guard oh I know I need to umph
and I need them all the way in me I feel
good right now I know Lord got it all
around
daddy oh thank you so much thank you
Thompson Lord I will go get counseling
oh my god I couldn't go do that no some
berries over there her and him
how would you better it's better I'm
gonna do some real a lot of things that
other women or doors are for me to come
up with uh with money to get some
because I don't go that extra day I just
saw getting food stamps money there's a
month yes I am and you know something
else only use correct like a new stroke
I've seen less than now did before I'm
gonna be out right I'm glad I'm here cuz
it makes me I can't go home they'll get
me that I'm didn't go get me that no I
stay here I think so scared being here I
just won my muffled roar I will do drugs
like I used to know most especially the
crash I try to smoke a little marijuana
it's not my drug of choice but it's a
downer then I music to suppress I don't
know no other way I wanna get you thrown
another drug appeals and shooting and
you've done them there don't do no good
to talk to in my fingers they don't give
it hell streets this drug not no none of
that I can't really pin on nobody but
the Lord and it's never gonna put the
people in my life to help me and when
they blessed me with things I barely
used it wise
cuz it's too many days I don't worry
when I anyway
without a person well what's he gonna do
for me I can't believe these me but then
that's my fault I won't hurt him pull
myself together get my mouth [ __ ] and
give me a job and that's what happens I
feel only streets here in California
bleak and it's so hard it's so hard Matt
be so holy sometime that's how we do one
gonna sleep over stand on the streets
these guy who go to sleep with clothes
on I got them your wake up with a mile
off huh can't go to sleep in these
people chance you ever get tired come
here
it ain't no you just see nobody you can
trust not family and not stepdance
not the people on the streets
I'm learning from my mistakes everything
I go do that the Lord allowed me to go
to I learned from and that's why it's
not to repeat yeah go on sleep somewhere
wake up and they got no goddamn clothes
off I want to do me me I just don't know
people like that in Houston to wake up
you don't have nothing oh nothing
yes whatever dr. Michelsen they had to
put something in something I drunk
offered me something to drink and it was
very had to be true later soda or
something but these people here I said
this is the city of Los Angels
I believe it's a lot of spirits here
it's a lot of spirits here I feel them
even in that building that I'm living in
it's a lot of spirits huh it's a lot of
spirits here I bet you're not gonna get
out and I have not let a man get to me
you hear me
I have not allowed want to come in my
life not just being my friend not
nothing you hear me no sex I've been
hearing you and they've done no sex can
you believe it huh my mind so messed up
from the mess happening with me women
daddy daddy
as I head over watch out I did the Lord
he gave me a boy cuz I'm I probably with
a bit overprotective we had to bless me
with a girl I'm gonna drug he hit me and
that is better than I used to be and if
me can't pay me they can't give me no
drugs no quick to help my body I'll for
me to sucked a dick yeah I always have
made me stronger stuff I'm going through
I don't care if I be hungry
my trying to soothe people I'm saying
can I have some money give me some me
you better believe it I'm already
because I won't go that that that other
extra mile to do the things that need
me and we want you to do to degrade
yourself I get all the job I work harder
than these mean I'm scared to do no work
I got calluses on my head ain't no air
man send me to the beauty shop Oh know
what I'd like to have one yeah my toes
and my nails there I'd be lonesome here
I've know some here
these ladies are not friendly it's an
epidemic going around and it's who is
Skid Row they have too much unprotected
sex they need some help trucks to come
out here in the sit up in this area here
if I was a man I wouldn't let a woman
stuck my dick without a condom you hear
me
these women don't go to the doctor these
women they don't try I don't so gonna
because I finna do nothing I'm gonna do
nothing
I don't care if I was judging what hit
him joke I was hungry I mean to put me
out of the cold
I think it's gonna I wouldn't get him
not don't cheer me I can come in out of
the cold and warm up and get some rest
nobody gonna bother
I heard that before not one good with no
goddamn clothes okay till I be some I
don't have sex with me or not and right
now let me tell you the Lord the Lord
God she wasn't in my life
ain't nobody made me believe that the
Lord don't have you in my life the Lord
got you in my life you better believe it
you better believe that so help me God I
ask that the Lord help you to fit it in
your heart the death the truth I mean
Craig don't do never tell your body job
and your immune system these are facts
that I'm telling you about this I gave
it a name I called it the devil love
potion him
you don't benefit from it I think the
Lord they don't select them on the drug
I think the Lord for and every time he
fix you well in the mean but you could
just I wasn't on the job
it's old time up in the head just kind
of money but when you give to me yeah
you know once way behind it and so I'll
be scared to miss him I don't know it
okay for the Lord to you that's been
opinion $800 Oh some drugs yeah I'd be
too scared I'd be too scared know that
dude and I don't I do all my stubby for
making my hundred dollars him not hard
it is when you give me that money and
just a to do right we lie all the way to
pity you're not hard that else for me
and I'm a drug addict I hard at it when
you give me everybody now walk out that
door the nice with my my own no trouble
it's very hard for me it's very hard for
me and I don't need I don't spend
another penny on it put the law take
them just like he blessed me to get it
he'll stop me from getting here he'll
stop me every time you say you want I
did right with him I did right Wilma
I got people be trying to try to
convince me to get stronger get stronger
you help us to be it could we don't hold
so much stuff in and don't let and we
don't talk to nobody about it yeah me a
little buy your Bible well you coming in
have to tell your story it's just like
it's just like going through something
that's therapeutic for you near me it's
therapeutic for me to get the things
that don't happen to me to talk about it
it's not in that hold it in it helps me
so there's so many ways you can be
helping us with the financial side to to
talk about it and get it off our I would
top something that's don't happen this
painful to you'd be helping us in so
many ways
they just don't be knowing that's why
it's good to bless the Lord for people
he'd be putting in your life and if you
ain't trying to get close to the Lord
they won't even see that you a blessing
when you really else be a blessing for
me you gonna always be a part of my
heart you hear me you will always be a
part of my heart
okay I gonna don't let you go he will
never let you know
yeah because out so it what to me but
you to hear me by what what so happen to
me that's important to me so I'm one to
me you don't nobody else we want to
listen to it okay I don't never let you
go I'll never let you go you never never
be to get rid of me what I mean
you